one thing I guess I realized a long time
ago was that self-help is not written by
people who know how to do the thing
about who people who need the thing
we're all right all right stuff that we
need the book of Austin was written
because it was the book I needed I lost
40 pounds of distress I moved downtown
for the first time I live alone for the
first time I think I'm ugly I think I'm
Undateable I have no confidence I take a
year to go online and start dating again
I take another year till I go on my
first ever second date but the whole
year of first date the person that want
to see me again okay not everybody likes
energy brother the first time in a
decade I'm like we live in Crazy
overwhelming times we need to talk about
carrying the ice cube tray from the sink
to the freezer without spilling anything
so what I'm trying to say is by doing
the Reps you just develop the skill
yourself and the market tells you what
works I don't trust the algorithm the
market there's no good news newspaper
man you know what I'm saying
has an amazing author sold over a
million books of his how many books have
you done 10 including the Germans how
many are in the awesome series there's
ten books in the awesome series well
there's the book of awesome there's the
book of even more awesome there's the
book The Holiday awesome there's the
Journal of awesome then I'm switching
yeah that's where we hung out live
together and you did a ton of awesome
stuff for your channel and I love all
you guys uh you know for reaching out to
me after that I still get emails from
this stuff we did like five years ago
the power of your YouTube channel and
then I did a book on resilience which is
I now regret the title it's called you
are awesome I kind of wish we called it
the resilience equation to kind of be
clear and then I did a picture book
because also called awesome is
everywhere and now I have a brand new
book called our book of awesome which is
right so I I have the the soft cover
like uh uh uncorrected proofs version of
it you're holding up the hardcover there
which is great so this is the more
valuable yes because this is uh you know
this is this is impossible to get except
for a few friends and uh and and you
sent me this note I won't hold the whole
yeah because it has some some of your
personal contact info on it so I won't
share that but but you got another book
another book felt like a dose of
positivity was needed and then I I saw
in the know the notes that this is this
is the last book in the awesome series
and there will be no more tell us why
this book now and why is the whole
series ended yeah sure so for people
that I don't have the background you
know I wrote the book of awesome 12
years ago it was through a time in my
life where you know my wife left me my
best friend took his own life I started
a Blog called 1 000 awesome things I was
like viral on the internet in the like
dig and farc days okay like early Reddit
world you know I'm talking like Cake
Wrecks fail blogs stuff like people like
like if you know that vintage that was
me okay so that blog got 100 million
hair to turn into a book called The Book
of awesome and honestly Evan after
writing three of them and like you know
calendars journals I just thought I got
two choices in life I can either do the
same thing over and over again like
Chicken Soup for the Soul sort of thing
or I can
try my best to figure out what else I'm
interested in and so for the past eight
years I did that I did the second I took
and none of those books is ever sold as
my as much as when you talk at the
beginning you sold a million copies what
you're really talking about is the first
few books you know what I'm saying and
so I just as an artist as a writer as a
Creator as a maker I always want to be
evolving I always want to be challenging
myself I have been working on a book
about trust for four years and I needed
to take a break from that book to write
something that just filled me back up
because I've been drained I've been
tired I've been overwhelmed the pandemic
it's just slapped me in the face and so
I decided to return to the original but
for the first time in a decade I'm like
we live in Crazy overwhelming times we
need to talk about carrying the ice cube
tray from the from the sink to the
freezer without spilling anything and I
love it well for the YouTube audience uh
check out the description we're gonna
link up uh the new book that you can go
check it out on Amazon what I love about
your books and one of the advice you
gave me so any aspiring offers use said
and I remember this some years ago is
make sure your book is breathable
so make sure that you can you can easily
pick it up and put it down and you don't
have to read like 80 pages of like tiny
text before because I'm the kind of guy
if I if there's like five pages in a row
and like what happened and I gotta go
back and read those five pages again and
it's like super tiny font and your books
are always just a masterpiece in in
breathability and your book I mean so
the awesome books are interesting
because yeah every page basically it's
his own little dose of awesome and it's
things that at least my interpretation
of it is things that are happening in
day-to-day life that you don't even
think to appreciate or have gratitude
for it's like that is actually pretty
awesome like my life is actually pretty
awesome even if all sorts of castes
happen around you so you know uh one
here is getting dressed out of the
laundry basket awesome redoing a high
five with a friend to get a better smack
you know awesome tearing off a piece of
plastic wrap this is like it's these
little moments that make you reflect
like man how many of these little things
have we done every day that we could be
grateful for but we we don't even think
of because it just naturally happens at
absolutely and you know here's the thing
um you know Stephen King wrote a great
Memoir called on writing and for anyone
who's watching who's an aspiring writer
I would really recommend that the funny
thing is and I wouldn't say that to
Stephen King I would chop the book in
half and I would chuck the first half
which is his life story the second half
is how to be a better writer and that's
the Masterpiece man that is the stuff
that's in the second half so that's
right heads up start the middle you know
if you just want the writing stuff and
he says when you flip through a book in
a bookstore what you're really checking
for is the air the space do you your
brain the way you are in your life fit
into that and there's times in my life
I'm up for reading you know a book like
uh infinite job holy cow dude that is
insane in pages of this time I'm having
PTSD just looking at that book you know
or you know
a bonfire of the vanities right like if
you feel like bonfire the vanities you
can go hard and you know what some of
these books at the written well they
Propel you through them but for me with
my attention span growing up on RT
Comics and Mad magazines with bolded
words and lots of exclamation marks I
was like I don't want a table of
contents I don't want an index I don't
want an acknowledgment I don't want to
about the author I don't want a
dedication I don't want any of that
mental shrapnel to interfere with what I
want to be a connection point with me
and the reader I'm well aware that this
book is a toilet book okay I'm well
aware that for most people it's a back
of the toilet you pick up you feel good
you move on or one before bed every
night or something like that it's like a
it's a It's called The Book of awesome
our book of awesome they're partly
because there is a Biblical connotation
I I don't I don't push that too hard but
just like the idea that you can open up
anywhere and ideally you could feel some
form of what you felt gratitude and
appreciation for what we have as opposed
to what we're taught to feel by the
endless streams on news media and social
media which is you don't have enough
we're Temple quickly are left feeling
with lack
okay the purpose of this book our book
of awesome is to help you feel does this
book pair with the journal that you had
before
yeah with two with two in the mornings
the one that's like right underneath
here as a prop to hold this thing up
uh two minute warnings uh pairs well
with it because what you do is you wake
up every morning if you're like me you
got to get your cell phone out of the
bedroom I got it 95 of people right now
are sleeping with their phones okay and
and I'm talking like check it before bed
sleep beside it check when you wake up
and and I know when the last time you
drank a bottle of wine before bed was or
slept within five feet of a bottle of
wine or drank a bottle of wine when you
wake up every morning but if you did any
of those things we'd probably call you
an alcoholics everyone's a phonaholic
now I'm saying get the phone out of the
bedroom start your day with two minute
mornings this journal is I will let go
of I am grateful for and I will focus on
so you prime your brain for positivity
with those three prompts and I can talk
about this one with the three again what
were the three research studies
supporting each one
uh I will let go of
okay like like you know you think
Catholic confession chamber you know
bless me Father for I have sand it's not
just Catholicism people don't realize
this uh Judaism Mormonism uh Buddhism uh
Islam almost all world religions have a
form of repentance of confession built
into the practice but we're throwing the
baby out of the with the bed with the
bath water here because our our
percentage of people who are religious
in society is dramatically decreasing
okay so Canada United States France UK
uh Australia New Zealand these countries
are all crossing over to more than 50
secular majorities
there's research that says when you
confess to something get off your chest
Journal get it out of you you feel
better I will let go of how many
subscribers I have on YouTube Compared
to Evan let's go all right he's got
three and a half million I've got three
for now for now he's coming he's coming
unsung wait just wait for it
then I am grateful for and this is where
our book of awesome comes in this is
look at the back the back of the
hardcover is 200. wow I'm jealous of
your back my back looks different I've
got like uh what this book is for I know
I let me look at both yeah let's go send
a couple copies to to get well and for
giveaways for your people man like I'm
happy to sign and mail some out to
people just spreading the awesome I want
I want the I want the idea of focusing
on the pauses to get out there there's
no good news newspaper man you know what
I'm saying other than like you know
tanks good news or whatever there's not
a good news newspaper and so I want this
book to fill a spot in our lives where
our brains need it I'm grateful Force
number two and the last one by the way
is I will focus on because you got we
got decision fatigue brother you know
this we gotta carve away all the things
we could do should do would do and make
one thing you will do today it's hanging
out with Evan Carmichael and tomorrow I
might be cleaning up my dirty home
office or it might be you know spending
special time with the five-year-old kid
who I haven't really hung out with
one-on-one in a week or whatever you
know what relationship fuel might I need
in my in my life as a father and so
those three prompts one more time I will
let go of I'm grateful for I will focus
on help prime your brain for positivity
for the day the middle one gratitude
this book can help but ultimately you
can also think of anything good that
happened in your own life the book is
meant to be a lever a tool a prompt some
slick Grace together
the mental shrapnel from before I was
crazy by the way I'm drooling the whole
time talking to you because of that
there's a whole story behind the Doritos
all right we can get into that if you
want but but I want to focus on you
because there's a lot of knowledge in
your brain they want to get out to my
audience
this is not a book that you read like a
book right and so that's like where most
people uh you see a book and you see
like oh my God it's so thick too like
that's gonna take me forever to get
through but you I don't know I mean
you've been doing this for so long you
probably have a ton of case studies and
testimonials and looking at the book
usually for me I'm a slow reader I'll uh
the goal is 10 minutes a day and I read
it before I go to bed and I read a book
and then I pick up yours and yeah it's
like I'm done a page in a minute
and then I kind of like I kind of want
more but I also kind of want to save the
next page for for tomorrow uh yeah and I
want to kind of reflect on what you said
to maybe that one example doesn't apply
but I can think of something else that
is also awesome so if somebody were to
instead of it just being like you
mentioned being a toilet but okay you go
to the bathroom and it happens to be
there and you pick it up and read it
like if somebody wanted to set a daily
intention or practice around I want to
have more positivity and awesome in my
life and there are how many in here this
is yeah
so like if you do One A Day you got
almost two years worth of of stuff in
here what what does a daily
maybe it's with a two-minute Journal
like what is a daily practice look like
to to learn something awesome and then
apply it to your life okay well I
already said get the phones out of the
bedroom but I didn't give you much
research supporting that there's
research from Australia app that shows
if you look at a bright screen within
two hours of bedtime and I hate to tell
you that number because it almost sounds
unrealistic but let me just tell you the
research if you look at a bright screen
within two hours of bedtime your pineal
gland in your brain does not produce or
secrete enough melatonin for you to get
into a deep restful sleep overnight so
what I'm advocating is I don't care what
time you go to bed you go to bed at
eight turn the phone off at six you go
to bed at midnight turn the phone off at
ten you go to bed at four in the morning
turn the phone up at two in the morning
have a gap between when you turn your
phone off and when you go to bed in that
Gap I want you to play a game you know
what I brought my cue cards with me here
today so I'm gonna grab a cue card got
my cue card here it's blank nothing on
it
rose rose Thorn Bud okay and instead of
this marker that doesn't work I'm in a
new marker that does and and if you were
to type in those four words into Google
anybody watching this rose rose thornbud
what comes up right away is a viral
article I wrote a few years ago on a
whim I was like ah you know I should
tell people about this silly game that
my wife taught me from her Camp days or
whatever
well no one else has written about this
thing it's a simple game every night
before you go to bed you know what you
do you say I don't you can be sleeping
beside your partner you might be tucking
in your six-year-old you might be
FaceTime you know not FaceTime and get
off the screens you might be talking to
your grandma you say hey Grandma what
was your Rose from your day what was
your highlight what was your
is there a new flavor of donut at the
coffee shop did you get an assistant
hockey practice did you get a couple of
from the boss did you did a truck go by
in the spot the slush didn't land on
your pants what is it give me one thing
okay the book is a tool to use when you
can't think of one okay it's a helpful
prom because it's like
you know finally unsubscribing from that
email you've been getting forever that's
super annoying when your kids don't hear
opening hear you opening a bag of potato
chips
um when the cake flop flops flawlessly
out of the pan uh sending a private
message during this Zoom call and seeing
your co-worker looked down and silently
smirk okay so you just say a couple of
these things right they say one back
then you do a thorn EV you know what in
all relationships you gotta have venting
space You Gotta Have venting space
doesn't matter what it is your job
despite us trying to solve all the
world's problems you just say ah honey
that sucks then shut your mouth no more
talking okay and then finally a bud
b-u-d-b-u-d a bun is something you're
looking forward to uh it could be this I
can't wait to make pancakes on the
weekend or it could be like I want to go
skydiving on my 100th year old birthday
whatever it doesn't matter if it's
tomorrow or 100 years from now Rose
restore button is a simple gratitude
practice to put into your end of night
routine off the phones I love it you
have so many examples in here you just
listed a whole bunch are these just you
are these crowdsourced are these coming
from your kids like how are you coming
up with all these like seemingly random
but amazing things that we go through in
our lives okay so this is a good
takeaway for artists makers creatives up
there no matter what it is you're
starting I told you I started this after
my wife left me when my best friend took
us on life well I started a Blog called
1 000 awesome things let's go
wordpress.com
you know I got like the ten dollar one
right uh and then you know I wrote my
first post it sucked broccoli flower the
strange mutant hybrid child of Nature's
ugliest vegetables okay then I'll write
the next one it sucked you know um
locking people out of the car pretending
to drive away at the gas station right
okay it just did I was figuring myself
out you know then I wrote the next one
fat baseball players then I wrote the
next one and then I started get
finding money in your old cold pocket
wearing warm underwear from out of the
dryer planning on Old dangerous
playground equipment so what I'm trying
to say is by doing the Reps you just
develop the skill yourself and the
market tells you what works I don't
trust the algorithm the market like does
your mom forward it to your dad and
double your traffic okay that's what
happened to me she sends that one to my
dad blah blah blah that post old
dangerous playroom it went viral guess
what happens if now I'm starting to get
comments when you start to get comments
from strangers as any kind of creator
online will tell you that's another
indicator that's another indicate
comments from strangers people you don't
know okay that's a sign like how did
this person get here well they start
leaving you suggestions the other side
of the pillow well wouldn't you know it
I write that one up into an essay it
gets really popular I open my first book
with it the first entry in the book of
awesome at the other side of the pillow
now for this book I reviewed over 15 000
submissions that were sent to me in the
back of the book of awesome the first
book in 2010 I said if you have an idea
email me you know a thousand dollars and
things submissions gmail.com well it
went back and locked and logged into
that email which took forever to figure
out the password and guess what over 10
000 people had emailed me and they
didn't just email me like I have an idea
email me like an essay like here's my
awesome things you know when the Roomba
goes around my house and doesn't suck up
on my bras like somebody sent me right
they send me random things well I went
through those things I curated them I
edited them and I worked into this book
about 20 of material from other people
and look I wanted it to be more I wanted
to be 50 but my publisher said
I want it to be less my publisher said I
want to be zero percent like I you know
when you're making anything with editors
and Publishers you have to come up with
the vision together it's it's it's
Lennon and McCartney you know it's not
this it's not so it's not Wings here you
know what I'm saying so they said
um we want to be less we came up with a
happy medium and so as the book
progresses
it starts off with entries from just may
and then as it gets going there's
comments then there's letters then
there's submissions and the end of the
book ends in a cacophony of Awesome from
voices around the world culminating
eventually in this endless sprawl which
again I took out all that remember I
took out all the others and then it ends
on the back page with two at the end
it's bam 200 more awesome things you've
just never seen anywhere before it says
they've never been written that anywhere
else just brand new and the very last
one the very last thing maybe I should
leave this as a surprise okay I won't
tell you but I can tell you it's at the
very last one is
reading every single item in a really
long list
I mean you know just trying to have fun
with it um playing it forward and then I
hit a QR code in the back so it's like
you know I took out all that shrapnel
but I still want to have a way to
continue the relationship with the
reader because one thing most authors
don't have is a relationship with the
reader their relationships maybe with
the publisher maybe with the books or if
they're lucky but not with the reader
and so that goes to a website where I
have all kinds of books of awesome walls
of awesome uh my wife of a teaching
guide for the book like all kinds of
stuff and then I just say here give me
your email and I'll email it all to you
and that way the email allows me to keep
connecting with them and then I send
them every month a list of book
recommendations which of course they can
unsubscribe for any time which I
understand unsubscribing from emails
because I also get too many but it's
just a way for people who want to keep
in touch to do so for me the Roomba one
is my iPhone charger it's all always
eating on my iPhone charger so like any
day where it does like awesome now I'm
gonna now I'm gonna think of that I see
my iPhone charger that hasn't been
destroyed by the room but I was like yes
it is but like it's it's here but it it
it's on the when it's not plugged into
my phone the cable goes on the floor and
then either it pulls it out of the wall
or the room gets stuck here because it
can't move anymore and so yes yeah I
mean I really should just move it
somewhere else that would be like the
smart thing to do but now instead
I could just say awesome anytime that
it's not uh it's not all chewed up
that's great yeah dude
um listen one of the things I admire
about you is you're known as the
positivity guy and let's spread hope and
less spread optimism let's spread
awesome and yet you then acknowledge
that like hey struggling through code
button like we need we need something
more so how do you how do you um have
the courage I guess to say hey I'm
supposed to be this guy but I also
struggle too and I'm sharing my journey
to try to help other people well one
thing I guess I realized a long time ago
was that self-help is not written by
people who know how to do the thing but
who people who need the thing okay so
Mark Manson cares a lot about stuff
right so he writes about the subtle art
of not caring about stuff James Clear
requires to create good habits so he
writes a book to teach himself how to
create good habits Atomic habit and I
don't mean to paint a blanket over the
whole industry like that perhaps there
are some enlightened folks amongst us I
just have never met them okay and so
what I'm trying to say is
the reason I think Tim Ferriss Advocates
writing a four-hour work week is because
he's workaholic and I don't I shouldn't
apply labels but I just mean because he
works a lot of course you can see that
look at the stuff he's making he's
putting up Pockets left right and Center
I'm just saying you can see the work
right in front of you so of course he
writes a book about how to chill out a
little bit we're all writing stuff that
we need the book of Austin was written
because it was the book I needed I lost
40 pounds of distress I moved downtown
for the first time I live alone for the
first time I think I'm ugly I think I'm
Undateable I have no confidence I
um take a year to go online and start
dating again I take another year until I
go on my first ever second date that's a
that's a whole year of first day person
that want to see me again okay not
everybody likes this energy brother this
is my true self right and that you know
so I'm just saying like then I read
another book about awesome things what
am I looking for awesome things I need
them okay I write the happiness equation
after my wife tells me that she's
pregnant on the flight home from our
honeymoon well I needed to figure out a
way to sort of codify the stuff I
learned about living an intentional life
I wrote about resilience because I have
thin skin if I get a nasty email or not
look people are like you know our mutual
friend you know Shane Paris was like
well don't you always get all positive
stuff I'm like the only Amazon reviews I
read are the one star you know the only
ones I see are the negative ones and and
you know Casey neistat always says the
ones that sting are the ones that are
true and so like you know the top review
on Amazon for for the happiness quiz
which is a book that came out seven
years ago I will say just a heads up
it's like from privileged white males
you know with fancy degrees and I'm like
that's the top review in all of Amazon's
privileged white males and I'm like did
they look at the name on the past
Reacher is Barry White is the name okay
well I'm not I'm not I'm not white but I
I will admit when I read my own book now
through the lens of seven years of more
learning I'm like yeah there's a ton of
stuff in that book that's super
privileged that I didn't even see at the
time and so what I'm saying is the
reason that stings is because it's true
and the reason it's reason I look at it
is because it stings and so what I'm
trying to say is zooming up a level it's
like I'm not the positivity guy I'm not
the happiest guy I'm a guy who is spent
12 years of my life trying to Wade
through the science and the research
following channels like your amazing
stuff and millions of others like all
the people we both know trying to figure
out who is gleaning Discerning
simplifying straightening out and
communicating clear positive content
that I can work and distill into simple
habits that I can use in my life and the
reason I advocate two minute warnings
and made it into a book is because I
needed it I needed it I was waking up
going on Twitter man so I needed I
needed it I can't go on Twitter I can't
be looking at a loud jangly Spanx ad at
6am like what's going on with my brain
it's not healthy so I write this thing
so that's what I talk about I talk about
stuff I need I need a book of awesome I
needed another book of awesome when does
the neopestricha awesome movie come out
and who plays you in it
[Laughter]
uh first of all the book of awesome has
been optioned for a movie three times
and the TV show so it's been optioned by
like big producers like Reveille that
did the office and you know and every
time the way it works is you get a a
small amount of money like a four figure
sum of money to get the option and then
they have one year to turn it into a
script if they turn into a script you
get six figures if that script gets uh
green light into a pilot that gets
screen lit then you know now we're
talking like a jackpot the problem is
that funnel that three-step funnel is
almost impossible it's like you know one
in a thousand books gets options and
then of the books that gets optioned
which mine has had three times one in a
thousand gets into a script mine has not
done that any of the three times and
then of the ones that get into a script
one in a thousand get greenlit into
something and so these days because
the entire method of all communication
has been massively disrupted by the Evan
Carmichaels of the world the truth of
the matter is optioning things into
movies is not what it meant anymore and
what we actually need to think about as
creators if you want your work to get
out there if you want your work to
spread is
where are the places people are talking
about the thing I'm making and how do I
talk in those places
and who plays in the movie
uh
I mean Hassan Minaj is a lot better
looking than me so not him
um you know uh I think uh kumal nanjani
I mean he got all buffed for the
superhero one so I don't you know I
think he needs to be a little noodlier
to be to play me and you know the guy
who was in uh you know uh
who's that other guy who's the other man
for a while there just was not that many
okay so I'm like trying to pick up but
you know I think everything's got in the
way of Hamilton now so you know any race
can play any race you know what I mean
and and so who plays me in the movie
I'll give you a couple actors who I
really like who I think are totally
underrated remember Topher Grace from
That 70s Show I was always like that guy
was like a similarly kind of nerdy
quirky character that I think I could
identify with what happened to Topher
Grace Ashton Kutcher huge Mila Kunis
huge what happened what happened to Fez
he's playing Neil in the next movie I
love it that's his that's his rebound I
can't let you get away without talking
about content because I know we've
talked a little bit about YouTube and
getting you out there and you do a lot
of work with corporations and I'm sure
that kind of dried up a little bit
overcover but hopefully he's coming back
now we're going in and speaking he spoke
at some of the biggest companies in the
world and helping them with their
happiness and all that and I mean you're
great with long-form content which which
crushes on YouTube but also with the
evolution of tick tock Instagram reels
YouTube shorts this feels like it's a
perfect
22nd at a Time video clip no yeah I know
you're right I think I'm 42. yeah I'm
40. you're not that much it's only one
year okay nice I know
I know and well Kevin Kelly is a is a
smart sage in our world you know for
those that don't know kk.org uh has
really impactful formative essays like 1
000 true fans you know he's a really
really kind of sage and he's the founder
of Wire magazine and of course was
involved with the whole earth catalog as
the editor before that so the whole
earth catalog as Steve Jobs says was
Google before the internet okay
so um he says that social media goes to
Revolutions and even our earliest
incantations are only 5 000 days old and
so what I'm trying to say is that you
know I was huge on the blogging world my
blog had a hundred million hits okay and
then the next thing was Facebook well I
have a hundred thousand followers on
Facebook because again I just started at
the right time then the next thing was
Twitter and I have 35 000 followers on
Twitter because I just started it like
relatively early but not early enough
and then on Tick Tock I'm telling let's
go I got two followers like literally
two two I got two two followers two the
number two on Tick Tock well that's
because I opened my account three days
ago so you see what I'm saying I think a
lot of it comes down to timing if you
listen to a lot of the I ask a lot of
the big podcasters you'll have a podcast
called three books and uh you're gonna
come on it and you're gonna we're gonna
talk about your three most formative
books and um
you know I've been really lucky I've had
huge guests on that show right like I've
had Quentin Tarantino and I've had brene
Brown and Malcolm Gladwell and and yet
my Show's not huge my show is very very
Niche it's very very Niche it's very big
in the book community and there's not
that big a book community so it's pretty
small and then I talked to a lot of
friends of Mines with podcasts that are
like 5x 10x 20x my show and whenever I
talk to them a big part they say is the
when the when is in a hugely
underestimated aspect of content
creation the when the when did you start
when did you get in and then I'll add a
third round which is when do you publish
okay so on my blog I was publishing
every single night at midnight a Daily
Post you think on Tick Tock I'm doing a
daily video no but you see you see what
I'm saying the when did you start when
did when did you get going and how when
do you publish those are questions that
I got one Tick Tock video all right
right so I haven't whereas Twitter I was
posting four quotes a day for five years
so that'll that'll naturally build up
your organic followers yeah well let me
throw something at you and whatever see
if it lands it's I'm always I'm I just
want to see more nearby streets in the
world you know I can't help it uh it's
still super early for short form content
right like YouTube shorts
hasn't even announced monetization
that's coming next year so like it is
the game right now it's super red hot
and it into next year will be the thing
yeah but I don't think you even have to
be the guy like just like you you
crowdsourced a lot of this book and you
wanted to do 50 more but your publisher
wouldn't let you well you could create
the the book of awesome our book of
awesome Tick Tock account and
crowdsource the content creation to
either the 500 whatever daily things are
in here or their own things that then
can be posted because you had 10 000
entries or whatever to to the book like
hey submit your awesome thing and we'll
post it on our so it doesn't even have
to be you sitting in front of the camera
dancing or doing something it could be
completely crowdsourced with just one
person kind of managing it for you
um and I think it really helped sell a
lot more books too it's funny you say
that because I was just approached by a
guy who has a really viral and big
bookstagram account and he said how come
you don't have a book Talk account or a
tick tock account for books and I said
uh because I haven't done it and here's
my excuse I gave and you tell me if this
is fear talking okay I said you know
Paul Graham has a famous essay called
maker schedule manager schedule well
I've always wanted to have a maker
schedule I don't want to have employees
I don't want to have meetings I don't
want to have you know Matrix teams
talking about what my goals should be
when you hear the large podcasters talk
talk they all often talk about their
team their meetings their you know I
don't want teams I don't want meetings I
want a maker's schedule which is a
schedule for somebody that has nothing
on any day you know what else I have on
today Evan nothing this is it I have
nothing else on all they have no
meetings before I have no meetings after
and that's the way I want it and so my
fear and you can tell me this is fear of
this is legit I was like I don't want to
have to be managing people to create
videos and blah blah blah blah he said
I'll fly to Toronto I'll sit down with
you I've got this huge fancy rig I'll
film you a hundred videos in one day and
that's enough content for a year and I
thought that's interesting but also I'm
like now you got to investigate what
you're doing it for and why you're doing
it and if I can get find Mission and
purpose and spreading gratitude and
positivity I usually can get there but
if I get around like working working
really really hard to make make more and
more stuff I lose myself in it because
truthfully where I'm happiest is with my
wife with my kids walking going for a
walk bird watching I got into bird
watching and the pandemic like a lot of
people
um going exercising going to the gym
reading a book reading Fiction it's all
the stuff I tell people to do so if I
was not going to take my own advice and
instead I was going to be managing a
team of 12 people making content for me
well I'm not really doing my thing you
know and and I also will say I started
this game or I started into this world
when I was
27 I'm 43 so I am tired I I've been
doing this for 16 years and you know um
I I have the young kids and they're not
going to be young forever and any graph
you look at says your kids grow up they
leave the house and you miss them for
the rest of your life you know and so I
don't want to I don't want to miss those
years if I had no kids or I had grown-up
kids or I had kids out of the house or
whatever I might be different but right
now when I've got four boys under eight
years old
any extra minute I have should be lying
on the carpet you know it should be it
should be hanging out with them and
that's the place I always get to is how
hard can they go in every direction I
need to focus on what matters and I get
back to if I have extra time it's
reading fiction going for a walk
exercising spending time my wife
spending time with my kids and I don't
want to hire a team people and I've
tried them before and I don't like it
because then I feel like I'm mad I mean
that's the first it's amazing
self-awareness but two I love the the
maker party you're making is writing you
know like you're making is writing books
and you're going to write your truth
book and you know writing it and like
you're probably gonna write books
forever and it's amazing I think with it
yeah yeah whether they whether you're
managing a giant team is not the answer
you being responsible and telling people
what to do to post on Tick Tock or
YouTube shorts it's like forget it
because now you have to learn the
algorithm and understand all those
platforms working like that's over you
even being the face is I don't think is
the answer like having the guy fly to
you and then you got to make all these
videos and now we need daily content
like that just creates more work I think
it's just like you have
an agent who's finding book deals for
you and you've you've figured out a
partnership where they're taking 15 or
whatever they're taking wait let's go
Adam thank God you find the atom for
this
monetization is coming to YouTube you
can even give them all the revenue or
you split half the revenue from the
channel and they're in charge of
crowdsourcing the content they're in
charge of filming the the the the videos
or you take your audience who bought
this book or all of your other other
Awesome books and say hey if you have a
20 second video about awesome that you
want us to share to our account
submitted to submit it to Jesse at you
know awesome.com right yeah it's just
finding that one person sure or it goes
to hello and like you don't touch any of
it and you don't even have to be the
face you're not recording any videos
it's one person who who loves the
mission you're already doing user
generated content just in written form
and actually in the videos
high quality high blood yeah yeah no I I
I I I hear you and maybe I should you
know this is the thing this is the
dangerous thing that happens when we get
together is that I walk away and I'm
like I got so many good ideas I'm Gonna
Do It All I'm gonna do it and then
here's the thing I I interviewed a guy
named Dave Eggers for my podcast three
books and Dave Eggers is the author of a
number of well he he put us out almost a
novel a year and he says to me I object
to having a long-term relationship with
any piece of technology like he has a 15
year old MacBook you know that he writes
on and um when I find myself getting
deeper and deeper in bed with the tech
conglomerates and spending more time
myself on social media and even if I
didn't have to do anything you know I
still check comments I still reply I
still check DMS or whatever I noticed
that I personally this is Neil I feel
more anxious I feel more anxious the
more time I spend on any form of Social
and I don't know what that says about my
physiology I don't know what that says
about me personally I just noticed that
and the things that make me feel less
anxious are getting out into nature
breathing the phyton sides which is a
chemical trees release to lower your
cortisol and stress so every time you go
in nature you're actually getting a
physiological boost right just from
going outside listen to Andrew huberman
you'll be looking at the Sunrise every
morning right am I right people so so
I'm saying I get a boost from that I get
a boost from strangers that's a big one
for me I get a boost from like riding
the bus taking the subway walking on the
street wandering around bookshops one
talking to strangers those five and ten
minute interactions where you're so open
and trusting because you know you not
going to see the people again
is those fill me up and I find that on
the social media I notice I become
performative
even today yes I'm still in my hoodie
and sweatpants but I'm like oh I gotta
shave I gotta I shave for you man that
doesn't look like you're ashamed dude
did you shave it okay I shaved oh they
okay okay
I like it
[Laughter]
but but but you know I I don't want to
be I don't want to I don't want to keep
my grip on my view too strongly so that
I don't
be introspective and and sit on it so I
really appreciate because you know I'm I
am envious and uh
odd by what you've built and created I
remember the very first time I saw you
years and years ago you even looked and
you said I can't you said something like
I shouldn't be winning in this game or
you know it was something like it was
something like around the spirit of what
you were trying to do creating for you a
love and a community that I could see
was touching you and really deep and
profound ways and I was like wow well
he's getting from his community is love
and I said I said YouTube comment seven
I said that's just like trash I said
YouTube comments are like just people
like nasty and you're like not on my
channel
I remember you saying that and then when
you posted that first video of us
together I was like amazed all the
comments were like Evan it's you know
it's it you know it's Jose from from
Chile and I just want to say like this
is up there with these other three
videos like what I took away from was
this and I'm like who are these people
like if this was the YouTube Community I
was familiar with maybe I'd like YouTube
more but I go on YouTube it's just like
hate vitriol you know that's what I see
because I'm not logged in and I just
look at the comments under anything you
know and it's garbage well if you ever
want to dive in there there are ways to
make it easy and uh not a lot of new
work uh I'm always happy to bring some
with you man to make it happen but
um last question you've done you've done
so much to help people and pour so much
joy and energy into others and you know
all of the books if if people were to
hold you in their prayers or their
thoughts tonight what would you have
them pray for for you
wow
big question
you know I I I hope I hope and pray for
this for everybody watching I I hope we
all
um I live lives where we feel
tethered uh it's destabilizing time for
reality right now we're revealed
tethered and connected to those that are
closest to us whether that is our
parents whether that is our children
whether that is our brothers or sisters
or Sons or daughters or boyfriends or
girlfriends or husbands or wives or we'd
be tethered and we feel safe and if we
feel tethered and we if we feel safe
then I believe that our best selves our
souls our our wisdom our truest voices
can be heard by us and we could give out
to the world that we could radiate the
positivity that the world so desperately
needs in those Smiles on the bus in
those conversations on the sidewalk in
those places and in all those situations
and places where we have to remember
it's us we're humans we we we we we're
it we're in charge not all the stuff in
between us it's us and then we got this
and we're gonna be okay and let's give
all of us a prayer for just living I
love it well the man is deal press
featured the book here it's called our
book of awesome we'll link it up YouTube
in the description below Neil thank you
for the time man the wisdom the
blessings always
can't wait to see you soon thank you so
much Evan and this amazing Community for
having me it is a real real real treat
and uh I really appreciate the honor of
being able to talk about our book of
Awesome with all of you guys and Evan
much love thank you man thank you cheers
did you see my last one-on-one with Nia
where we talked about how you can sell a
million books check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see
I'll see I sit down with Neil pasricha
the New York Times best-selling author
of six books which have sold over 1
million copies and spent over 200 weeks
on bestseller lists